okay everybody it's your boy
psychobabble and then I'm gonna play and
forgotten him
mementos where's the you asked for I
care okay
yeah yeah sure what is that a little any
but that's all this time I had the
memory I forgotten Helena mescaline I
have a star right in town I just took my
things in the white sock out with you
Eric how's his brave soul so now every
great legend is made up of little
stories stories of friendship of payback
about love and secrets and here's why I
want to start and that's a house over
here okay it's fine
very small house but yeah ii it's it's
actually appropriate for them lighting
but no case we're just starting it's
finally and very close the hybridization
of working lovers are responding very
well
electricity Mandrake extract on that K
of course
hello Eddie I'm sorry to interrupt but
my husband but um I wanted I got what
what are you working on those lamps my
wife why manager come here I know why
did you come here and deny for better
yet at the laboratory Sam I love what
I've no choice this is too important get
her get her
hey you got her yes better hope you
don't give me a lovely bride now and a
bother you here man one day we'll see
each other again there that as a weekend
by weird sun's coming up in the basement
I already imagined what I was about to
deal with okay so I got a K yes this is
this is child's play
well I just want way to fasten to all
this I can't miss all that whoa
yeah mr. frog okay and down get miss
responds right down left right
[Music]
dang it no one knows what this whoa this
is freaking scary what's going on this
guy okay what time is that the REA dread
o'clock that guy bro oh um okay I see a
thing yeah and there's so much stuff
here it's supposed to be three o'clock
Jesus
come on oh my god that oh yeah okay
that's the time right now
wait you gonna find like the actual time
of that thing
okay freaking out it's gonna be hard
game jizz
there we go
that guy got a kick anything these
pockets now Jesus right here
guess it doesn't go there just kidding
no makes a little sense dude there is so
much stuff going along this game holy
crap I don't even know I'm gonna get
this dude this is kind of hard actually
honestly I don't even know what I was
supposed to be doing here and let's see
here
holy crap oh okay
you seen anything
okay I got to talk to some music when I
says up that she goes like I think the
developers [ __ ] how do I get back again
there we go what
thank you Ken let's see here
okay hello say like this is something
dude the all this that was so
complicated holy smokes
I can't wait what is that door
and
[Music]
1 3 3 8 1 3 3 4 2 1 3 3 4 2 that mean
anything doesn't mean squat doesn't mean
I say nothing
1 3 4 - yeah there we go
ok that's the order um circle circle
triangle X square I remember then circle
triangle X square and your just circle I
got a sword I got this freaking okay
guess up with the sound back on
so what you wear that sound
[Music]
there's an order of right crab you can't
frickin tell what do I have it X you
think I said second
Eileen but the short ahead side perfect
okay
and now this hard game no this game
okay I need about a dark wait
how the heck wait won't
okay I'm Mustang
actually just came out there at all
this has a cat here though
okay okay we got black black black
there we go what's the rest two squares
I did it I did it okay
oh that's good this thing oh crap Oh
Theodore no there we go
all right training ground that's
beautiful flower
thank you let's go I do this yep
I think with the flower go yeah right
there got another king it's a cookie
anything I figure what that is in a
second and I just see here yeah
what
oh I don't even know what is going on
there
freaking what if I see this I can't wait
holy crap
so supposed to be 5 4 2 3 1 5 4 2 3 1
okay Roger with the gun
this favorite okay I still got this eye
thing it's probably this PI up to solve
a puzzle
okay down left left left down what the
hell get a happy sa Oh was it the hand
thing okay let's see here right five
times
wait what yeah right
there we go we got the last mask do you
have a tosses right let's shoot it take
a penny or something
can that go in the door just be here
yeah that's big enough sorry sucker you
know I had the devis but thank you thank
you for your kind it feels like some
kind of presence it feels like some kind
of presence took strength by my act and
that's why if I wish yes I had to burp I
really wish you could rest in mass but
now I know that tomorrow we'll see each
other again
yeah that night after the night after
that forever even those things they play
parents and our letter I'll come back
[Music]
mm-hmm okay look care the story I'm
lighter it's been nice everybody thanks
for watching I hope you all had a great
time and if he did it and that's okay
that noise
thanks for watching y'all then again
okay it's your boy psychobabble and
we're back and we're with this guy with
the dark eyes yeah so I had had no
choice but to mediate like the music
just goes endlessly I don't like how I
can't just turn out the music keep the
sound that's the part that drives me
insane
right yeah it's like okay you know I'll
keep it on one of that not great just
kick me out all right when you found
everything come back for me here I'll be
waiting for you okay close this menu
Sara the top hat mr. horsey okay feet
feet let's hear what okay I need a book
a heart jewel a leaf over B and a brain
that's okay yeah that's not you
shouldn't be too hard
what's going on with this dude this is
like a very puzzling oh oh okay
mr. clockwork that's what we're dealing
with today man a lot of stuff going on
here well okay how do I get out of here
how do I not be here
is there a way in here wait did I
seriously get strapped I can't hang out
of here okay book heart jewel leave Ruby
that's fine
why how can I you go anywhere okay
fascinating how do I get stuck how do I
get stuck here oh there's a clue that's
insane I don't even know that can happen
well alright let's see me actually I'm
stuck here he got the brain to put that
mr. clockwork West our clockwork
what is going on here
I think there's a reset the last chapter
that might be trapped here okay am i
literally trapped in here okay I'm just
gonna YouTube this and see what is going
on here I'm on okay forget for gotten
him ma'am memento as I was called yeah
okay um to chapter 2 there we go
come on bro
huh
huh
hmm okay well turns out this is correct
and it's literally sorry the one screen
so I found out but just by finding us
one thing so now I know that each of
these goes home number so it's six three
six three five six three six three five
six three great I can't with you that
now six three five six three to help I'm
supposed to be a five six three hips
five six Thank You there we go whoa okay
now we're getting somewhere
okay Kubica is a little taste in music
okay we got this so we can do this now
perfect gave me a key take this game go
right here I got a bunch of this and
okay so we got the jewel it's got to go
upside down he is hungry and he is
laying on his back holy crap they just
gave me freaking everything Oh
okay what is that book I got the book
jewel pickaxe and go down here so the
horsey key icon there no no either heart
right heart jewel leaf where we embrace
you I hate these things
mmm-hmm oops well oh these thinking
switch anywhere they'd be like right
after each other why it's so easy then
tells this I'm Monica here am i sir sir
thank you for giving me that brain
bottle with blood I don't have to leave
oh crap I supposed to sit back uh I got
to leave okay how's that hair sir
hey I got father I found every last item
on that list
I get so now listen to me carefully and
now you're very close to Barry but it's
time I scum
blaze all three items inside the
pentagram I drew oops
yeah right there sorry Barry
Holy Smoke that was clean it was pretty
easy and what's going on now he's going
uh he's gonna start wreck land space No
Oh
Barry's back and stronger than ever not
everything that is lost is lost forever
okay okay even though the episode was
horrendous well no oh I'm just right up
for this that yesterday
okay guys are back when I moved with my
daughter
Kamel Camille Camille tea chamomile um
in this new house and forgotten Hill I
was still hurting we lost my little boy
been though a full year had passed so
does that but spiked him chamomile tea
yeah oneness often took hold me as I
wander through the house worms I get it
but then one day I saw her a wonderful
vision a shadow then light my life and
there for the first time in a long time
I no longer felt like a ghost
all right chamomile sit down doc'll on a
big love blossom Bush burn show me I
could bring her back into the world and
tell me what to do oh okay I guess she
told me but the narrative not telling me
so I'm just basically doing the whole
thing now by myself
you know if she told you you could just
kind of tell me okay top bottom
dang out sent yep oh great
da hell I'm gonna up desk
wait you shoulda been out that I can't
really tell that's on the ground No
yeah he's disgusting okay so annoying
I really have no idea okay
one two three there we go
[Music]
now this
okay
choose Chris
there we go
got a second metal disc and I can deal
with that later
how they get out here okay what that's
annoying
my god there's so much okay freakin a
moon equals fine with him
and
needs to be 11 now at 12 6 9 10 11
freakin a Keys lightest well this one is
actually tough okay
7 there we go
ornament another metal disc holy crap
okay so it was better tell me freaking a
what the hell is that I'm missing a
disco the innermost desk but it should
be I used ornament
yeah I got the medal desk okay being us
so ugly
oh crap crap crap okay okay
Ruth I supposed to know this I get back
to it oh crap
that old letter so Jesus skip them
[Music]
where does it itch there we go I've got
a fuse okay thank you some of this feels
real quick
guess not ok let me get a good look at
this
okay I think I pretty much got it oh
crap okay
here we go
right thank you that was not scary at
all
okay back up back up
I know it's kind of a quick
it's as simple yeah this guy's hideous
and wreck
okay
oops
oops
hmm yeah that stuff oh it can go things
like that okay
if I ever got to do it you that's my
love bring camel here we need some of
her energy don't worry she's young she
won't be harmed
okay alright you bring her here no and I
bring her here yes yes can we go out to
her father but only after I get the doll
you promised me well I gave it to you so
nice fantastic fantastic much easier
than I thought
hairy gal juice up probably brighter my
last wish II know we can be together
okay thanks old fool now hi Ruth can
finally live and act again this world
your love has been very helpful
don't worry for cam if she still live
right inside this tastes a little doll
take care of her well house a happy
ending unless everything love with just
my illusion I sent my daughter wait to
live with our cousins I can't take her
anymore
care anymore loneliness is dinky hold me
again stronger than ever I just have one
more thing to do how's it Jenga
no a hammock I get it a hammock so fun I
guess alright that yeah man i sorry
well what is that a little hat right
there again well that's this what is
that adios muchachos okay we're on the
next episode days obscure loves have
desperate ends got a little fireball go
yeah got that's my charge oh yeah got
this
we always live peacefully ain't
forgotten heaven lasts a day something
has changed
first there was a word accident that
killed the butler then again another
absurd actually took my beloved away
from us well my son is all I got now
hope this terrible thing won't take that
boy from a town Jesus okay
I think I guess I find that Pez on a sec
okay so I'll find that pestle as well
can take a letter
not quite sure what that is oh it's like
a t-rex or something that's funny
jeez Chris
and eyeball what and as an eyeball
I mean she's a little tough
how it told it right crap
that's a tough one
what is that can't know
pictures peace
amps
get another picture space
okay
yeah
there we go
Oh God
yes
and tap
what
No okay this is going north
let's go east south south west west
this is the north piece of Italian
square triangle pac-man okay yeah yeah
don't do that that's hot
square oops triangle
pac-man
Yeah right now
again
okay wasn't machete down there why 20
doors here okay
guess that's not it yeah psychopath Tim
oh right here
okay
okay well you want to go ward she's
crazy I'm never gonna remember that one
okay
Egyptian I know crap okay to hold that
one okay that's the Egyptian
holy smokes I do not as 1 ohm Egyptian
home Chinese yes Indian
okay hips now okay well this has to go
all the way over here
there we go don't know how that was okay
toy soldier
not great
how'd that help I mean I got to take a
picture of this amount or something
I can't let me go see that toy will work
thanks but like another oh my god
okay Harry curious
what
three plus
what the heck
you
no I'm gonna need a piece of a4 this is
actually crazy don't you gonna have a
pen okay yeah okay
Jesus really messed that one up
shame of us got a sneeze I love sneezing
okay
hmm
okay so at least we know square equals
three
now that means a circle is five I circle
with this thing equals five if one sec
because basically what happens is this
Plus this equals three so then three
plus two equals five that's five five
plus three equals seven seven minus two
equals five all them right okay three
five seven five okay all these numbers
down here
oh that's the order you got a plan man
okay
well I miss know something this has to
be three so the first thing to do is
press this guy yeah three plus two
equals five
five plus three equals eight okay so
this is six
okay I got the order
thank you
as you want her right now I usually a
second toy soldier sir
anyone take it take this wet with toys
perfect perfect perfect
what the hell
okay
dan is messed up okay
and okay here we go
good can't do anything here oops
when we go
and one two three four five I don't know
when you go
hey leave me
Oh
what the hell is that just definitely
clear
don't really show in a sense
Tok Tok Tok
maybe Whitsett
it possibly that there's one two three
four five and then when you click on it
it's only four that's Illinois
I'm perplexed here
on two
to help
look for that infinity sign somewhere
know what to do here
oh it's joke not Tok
there we go
have you had an ornament wow this is
like so it's like amateur hour just like
so easy
mmm okay here we go one two and then the
bottom three
okay it was that No
one yeah that's what it was
Jesus Christ
no Kaylee's has the odor crap no just
kidding
one two three four five six there's me
okay that's fascinating
all right deck oh crap miss what he said
who who takes the highest card wins
taking this guy seven heck any of us
okay yep that's that episode it doesn't
matter what you're playing it you must
play on to the end you heard the boss
you heard the boss okay babies we're
back at it I don't know what's going on
here hello sir
hello woman that kid is so disgusting oh
my god now we're in the house now can't
get there okay huh
like on
the hell can't say crap okay
oh so I can go to any of them know how
last once well cho-jen we're talking
about important things I'll play
somewhere else
what the hell hey yeah look they're
banning way they carefully eyes town
mind the sky feet on the ground
where's the heart
guess we're gonna weigh something on the
scale I guess oh my god oh my god well
fail
fast growing potion iron chromate iron
that's methane methyl
they're just not enough it's just not
enough Oh
takes a second half
so I got it
I guess I got it okay where they tell
tract
so maybe I got to give it to know it I
see I think up up down down
there we go I got this girl
what's in here hello my style
huh 10 whoa
huh Joe right no one too
holy crap but tell
there we go that's a stupid one I'm
trying to Dallas
stupid
hey that's it no just kidding it's not
of course that's not
hello mother
check the blank roundup can't see crap
there
oh this is so quiet
there's something the right thing we
just check that side I'll take that oh
this is a side
Oh
can't get back to my friends without
wearing a mask
yes step ahead all right
dude I do not remember this
there's tears
one two
there we go so it's those tears
empty bottle perfect
hey light tapping cap cow
I got my mask I got my record
great match brother I'm gonna find mine
I think I looked at her father fellow
scientist home
nope that one's done
don't know that has
okay clearly we're not ready for this
yet
yeah
can't say crap here jaysus No
don't know what the hell's going on
there
there we go the hell get up get to ice
up in the lieth little sink its teeth it
there what the hell
my god
what the hell
this is K go
I check this place out so I don't know
what the hell this is
Cathy Lanier
and I think Anna's one of them
there we go
this rumor song
holy [ __ ] let's get the [ __ ] out of me
he's gonna Cammie
you need to make sure nothing else on
this side okay
oh crap
and
okay
how's that
ah
can I forget this
okay so I guess I can feed it to the
creature
I don't like heat the drag that's all I
like
there he as he died hey it in like that
come on Joe
okay I'd done this already
can't come back to my friends to that
wearing a mask well that's obvious holy
crap
Oh tiger
I got up a flower that machine keeps
coming back I can't stop her I don't
know what at least maybe a bit of love
and Kang
okay
there we go baby up thank you
get there anything with this [ __ ] can I
what is this five right for right
can't be it
this is a self sub thing that gives me
that juice to make the flowers are put
in out of the machine their time anyway
this is all very strange okay I got that
music
goodnight she comes back at midnight
there we go
yeah wake up baby
yeah with a spider I should have known
go ahead little what
they're down
crap
Erico
him
triangle circle diamond fuzzy okay
trying a circle time fuzzy okay don't
sound on
Wow she's disgusting
okay
take this okay what is that
[Music]
and it's uh computers down
okay like that Pearl Earring me my mask
how do I get that
crowd airing
well okay I guess at the mask
oh it was I supposed to say that guys I
now
okay I got the eye
hello sir Sabbath to
okay I got that perfect
okay
I can
Hotel
okay can't take these people up boom
right I don't want this
nope
go play somewhere else
let's do the earrings
thank anyway whereas instruction with
the hairless on two three four okay down
okay
the brain and the heart need to be up
the brain I don't know the heart down
when I get that from
laughter I go hard from dead
so can I get in there yes stupid-head
can you step it up how's it look out
here
hey this music so dull okay
hey we do something here right oh well
no the heck
not really sure and that goes
and it's near
what is it this forgetting something
well what
okay gotta make something that'll kill
the spider
now
you can find out what the rest is and
plus debt and time
okay that's how much yellow was a lot
that blue
and I wish for spider-man I stomach and
I stand my loss spider
okay I guess it's better just good to me
what
what the hell
and I really didn't not now
anything I'm supposed to be doing here
what al
get our earrings
when the few puffs will haven't got yet
or this one
I don't have the heart down
Tampa's anyone
today's three four four o'clock
okay go all the way back I guess
No
that's disgusting
canthus anymore
you should get there my heart from there
Wow
well
okay so I just looked and it is the
smallest most annoying trivial spot in
the whole game okay so we're just kind
of got there because there's no way it
would've been like ten years before I
don't found this out no Jess no sorry
sorry wrong room
just to go on to here and you know what
that means if I got this light now we
can go in the other place ain't nobody
what I forgot that oh my god what that
was us
mm-hmm
okay okay
in the Sun we are one in the Sun we are
one
so definitely can't go this way so I got
to go this way
there you go there we go
there you go there we go
and I see why I do here and okay hey
clever little one huh you are a clever
little one
here we go
I mean Dennett up Jesus what
Jason Kreis
well this one is really annoying
well this is a really tough one
[Music]
ooh so close
this is tough that's how
Sam
wow that's actually really tough
here we go we did it what the hell
this is so annoying it's a sound
annoying yeah just so annoying yeah just
an hour yang it's just plain annoying
nothing creative about it no no no it's
really nothing creative at all
nothing creative nothing creative at all
again
Harry how I did it and watch us how he
smokes out is annoying but
what am I doing here
okay
and I could get all the people to the
right side okay with their esophagus
week ten hours long
okay
this is a very annoying puzzle and
obvious how to do it it just it's just
plain annoying it's just plain annoying
yep that's honest just annoying just
annoying it's just annoying
I know yeah yeah yeah yeah it's just an
annoying puzzle it really ain't nothing
else I do about it yeah oops
thank Eric oh yeah we go
hatchet
whoa what the hell that is scary that
and let my side they're okay
oof good job just do it looks like okay
this dude okay the first guy is
well Eddie on stickam wow that's
annoying
I can't get da mo see that do want to
play now
mm-hmm
can I afraid this day
is that it yes
today I wanna hop outside just trial is
just in case
how is that
no nothing is missing
what
don't know that's about
okay it's so annoying so annoying
mm-hmm
yeah I can't get the mask my idea for
here
now with a complete mass now it's
suddenly the key for that
okay so she needs to mass now
how that sorry
Wow yeah can I cut this can I chop this
down
okay
something is missing something is
missing
got hair grows
ready right left left right left
right
okay
I get a photo this whole thing or
something yes
okay
we did it puzzle actually okay
okay let's see what we know that sorry
this goes here but I'm not how sure
now that's just wrong
it's tufted you guys think it's so easy
it was actually like tough
whose goes over here
okay well this basically can only go
here
you can just freakin skip puzzles he's
serious bro brow what the hell
okay
okay well I got another one these
puzzles I guess that alright
okay Wow
okay where that doubling up
can I also not be diagnosed I
this one's too tough
this one is tell annoying
I'm a genius how a genius
get out of your Clyde
okay
perfect
that wasn't here
I would I would have never got that
yeah
now get here
one two three
huh one two okay thank you sir
no7 there now
thank you sir okay
that Epps all right connect how was it
again sorry
all right no no no
mind in our
I mind fetal heart
that was that down downs out that far
room downtown okay
down down square up up Oh
salt surfer in chickens and bones
I don't have time for this bye though
step on the ground
okay I think it's this guy
no no the next one
salt surfer soul for ancient coins now
bone yeah it's all for dead
it is again Sano
how that
dot slash slash
what
oh crap I wrote it was just give it no
dot like so far it looks annoying
I got the hand of glory yeah yeah yeah
yeah I suppose is this about what this
room now
I think I've seen the head glory
somewhere oh wow
okay
said pumpkin seeds grow on the wall and
grave
pumpkin guru and I want power now
problem now problem that problem
yeah I got it
out now
how's that is that can I help you
was to play a prank on them
- the Bell - speaking went off and
hearings introdution - revenge
I think guess that's that
no I don't know I feel about this game
it was all right
all right it's all right